one of the more disturbing stories not
because anyone died or it was
particularly gruesome it was a
disturbing story about where our culture
is headed it was a local news story
about the metaverse about how we're all
going to plug into virtual reality and
mark zuckerberg is going to control the
world and we're going to leave the world
built by god and we're going to go into
a world built by mark zuckerberg isn't
that going to be so much better and
in the news story they said the future
not just of commerce not just of
schooling
but of the future of church is going to
be in the metaverse
metaverse is an online platform where
people can use virtual reality headsets
to transport themselves to any realm
they wish including church jackie bagnes
explains the appeal of digital
worshipping in the metaverse
i believe the future of the church is
the metaverse a growing number of people
are turning to the metaverse for their
religious services as folks pop on
virtual reality headsets and partake in
digital church let me have someone read
verses 19 through 21 but just because
it's virtual doesn't mean it's less
interactive than going to a physical
house of worship if anything vr church
participants say it enhances their
religious experience i was able to see
a rendering
of the verse i was reading which made
scripture much more meaningful
for me and it's so much more than
scripture readings baptisms are also
taking place in the metaverse the
rebirth that you got through jesus
christ do you want this yes
yes i baptize you but this kind of
worshiping isn't just for the text savvy
baptisms are not taking place in the
metaverse that's the problem
maybe people think that when they log
into their video game and have their
little character put their head under
the little digital water that they're
they're being baptized they're not
they're not
they're not going to church
even in the video game
they are they're playing a video game
our faith christianity
is an incarnational faith it's so
incarnational that the second person of
the trinity the divine logic of the
universe took on flesh
he was was incarnate
of the virgin mary
incarnate
conceived by the holy spirit incarnate
of the virgin mary and became man
and became man at that point when you're
reciting the creed in christianity you
you actually get down on your knees
because it's
this is the central fact that god became
man took on flesh and what these
heretics are trying to do
are is take the flesh away
and this has huge even if you're not
christian even if you're not
particularly religious this has huge
implications for your politics charlie
kirk the other day got in trouble with
media matters because he made a point
that i've made on this show dozens of
times that transgenderism is such a big
focus of the left not only because
they're creepy
perverted sexual theorists on the left
who want to upend all traditional sexual
mores but
because they want to
get rid of the flesh
they want it to be a stepping stone into
transhumanism
they want to say that your your body
doesn't matter your location doesn't
matter your family doesn't matter your
nation doesn't matter real reality
doesn't matter we can just be
transported wherever we want in the
metaverse go into your pod work on your
laptop and isolate yourself
that's what this is about a denial of
the importance of the flesh
but you can't have that real community
real
worship real life
happens with your body not on a couch
not with some goggles on not living in
some dystopian hell created by mark
zuckerberg
take the goggles off
go into real life the sunshine is
beautiful and the church is much more
beautiful two
ah
gotta ring the bell then you get
notifications if you're not getting
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you